very good morning to you welcome to the
breakfast show here on Sky News it is
seven o'clock a very special program for
you live from dining street again today
you can see number 11 Downing Street is
behind us this morning the weather is
changing could it be an Indian summer
for the prime minister or is she facing
a winter of discontent we've got some
breaking news from the treasury tomorrow
is here tomorrow good morning morning
Kay well we've learned in the last hour
that the chancellor will be delivering a
big financial statement this morning the
treasury announced at six o'clock this
morning before markets opened that
Jeremy Hunt would be bringing forward
some of the measures in that plan to
balance the books which was due at the
end of the month following discussions
with the prime minister at Checkers over
the weekend there is a growing sense of
urgency in government that they need to
show their changing course we expect
there will be more u-turns on the mini
budget in that statement potentially
putting back plans to cutting income tax
okay let's let's have a look at what the
Tweet says from the treasury it happened
just after six o'clock this morning
retweeted very quickly after that uh by
the new Chancellor saying that there
will be a statement from the chancellor
this morning then he will go to the
house to speak to MPS later on this
afternoon that in itself is quite
unusual because normally we hear these
statements in front of the Chamber of
the House of Commons first that's right
and the reason that's not happening is
because Parliament sits late on a Monday
sits in only in the afternoon on a
Monday and I'm told by sources at the
treasury and it's clear in that
statement that the chancellor wants to
reassure the market before they open
this morning that's why they've taken
this unusual step and it's already been
welcomed by one of the government's
critics who is the chair of the treasury
committee Mel stride who said it's a
wise move to surprise the markets on the
upside and show as he put it that the
chancellor gets it and knows that they
have to change course so
absolutely let's just run through what's
happened over the weekend as we know it
so far the chancellor was appointed on
uh Friday afternoon
um early afternoon that's when we heard
about it I'm sure there were discussions
before that although we believe that he
wasn't contacted until Friday morning by
this uh prime minister quasiquiteng was
called back from America where he was
speaking to the IMF he'd had
conversations there called back early I
realized on the way back to Downing
Street that he had been sacked then what
happened so we got our fourth Chancellor
in four months Jeremy Hunt took over
went straight to the treasury and then
in a series of media interviews on
Saturday morning made clear that he
would be rowing back quite substantially
on the prime minister's plan on which
she got elected by conservative party
members barely a month ago he said that
they had been Flying Blind by not
getting in an official forecast and
clearly they had not come up with a plan
to balance the books he made clear that
they will be going off in a totally
different Direction and we'll get the
first hints of that this morning we've
had one U-turn already perhaps we'll
come to those if I may let me also ask
you about what happened on Sunday first
of all
so on Sunday we heard more from the
chancellor again talking about mistakes
being made and we saw an escalation of
the campaign to frankly topple this
trust from among conservative MPS we've
now got three conservative MPS publicly
saying the Prime Minister needs to go
one of them Crispin blunt used to chair
a select committee said the game's up
are the conservative Grandes who are not
MPS the likes of George Osborne the
former Chancellor saying she will be
gone by Christmas now of course that
leaves the vast majority of conservative
MPS quiet publicly but privately many of
them including her staunch supporters
say something needs to change and
quickly okay Andrew bridgen amongst
those as well that's already called for
the prime minister to resign she called
her Chancellor to check us over the
weekend in fact after he'd done the
media round yesterday morning that's her
obviously home away from home if you
will in the uh in the countryside just
outside London
um he came back yesterday afternoon
where is she the prime minister is in
Downing Street this morning she
obviously came back either late last
night or early this morning but she is
in Downing Street today it is a decisive
day for Liz truss's Premiership Jeremy
Hunt is going to almost certainly
announce more u-turns to the to her mini
Budget on which the economic program on
which she was elected tax cuts which she
said would achieve economic growth
others take a very different View and
she will spend a lot of today Shoring up
her support among Tory MPS she'll be
meeting a big group of What's called the
one nation group of conservatives this
afternoon and this evening she will be
meeting her cabinet in order to talk
them through what is her plan because
there is a very real chance and it's
being openly discussed among groups of
conservatives that she will be ousted
from office in the short term okay if
you're just tuning our way you're
watching this guy and used a special
program for you live from Downing Street
this Monday morning it's a decisive day
for the Prime Minister we're giving you
a quick fire a Roundup of what's been
happening over the last couple of days
and then of course we'll go much more
in-depth fit into what we might hear
from the new Chancellor when he makes a
statement about mid-morning and then
we'll hear him in the House of Commons
later on this afternoon the Prime
Minister meeting her cabinet ministers
to try to get them all on side later on
this evening the question that a lot of
the papers are asking this weekend
tomorrow is is the new Chancellor a
trojan horse
yes lots of questions about why Jeremy
Hunt a respected former cabinet minister
someone who has a very successful
cabinet career under his belt already
why he went in to do that job now Jeremy
Hunt said yesterday he had no more
leadership Ambitions himself having run
twice he just wanted to try and do his
bit for the country but you know it is
no secret that there are some in the
party there are strong groups in the
party who want Liz truss replaced by
somebody else and there is no hard and
fast information here but you have to
wonder whether he is considering whether
he would stay on if that if that process
were to happen but I think at the moment
you've got the chancellor making a
statement this morning more u-turns
expected and that is intended to calm
the market and buy Liz truss a bit of
time because if she is even to get to
the end of this month when the full plan
is announced and that full plan is going
to involve difficult spending cuts we
won't hear those today I don't think
we'll hear those at the end of the month
she needs she needs to be bought time
for that process to take place okay as
tomorrow was saying they are circling
the wagons already crisp and blunt no
fan of the prime minister at the best of
times this is what he's been saying
I'm afraid they're blindly obvious
conclusion is that she must uh not least
in her own interests but most
importantly for the government to be
able to carry credibility and to be able
to bring the conservative party uh
together to get us back in a place where
we can deliver sound finance and sound
Administration
yeah the thing to remember though
tomorrow I think is anybody that knows
Liz truss will say that she's even more
custard and determined than Boris
Johnson
say she's very determined she has been a
real Survivor during her many years her
eight years in cabinet she's taken some
knocks and she's she's moved on but she
I think speaking to many conservatives
over the weekend they felt that she
looked a bit defeated in that press
conference on Friday she was they
thought it was a very disappointing
performance she didn't really give a
sense of how she felt she'd gone wrong
how she was going to get it together it
all felt very Theresa may-esque nothing
has changed we're still carrying on with
the plan with a couple of little tweaks
and that's not what many in her party
are indeed the country wanted to hear
and and I think they are going to want a
much stronger statement you're hearing
today Labor are already saying the Prime
Minister herself needs to come to the
House of Commons and account for the
fact that in kierstama's words she's in
office but not in power who is really in
charge and what is the plan because that
is not really clear to many in her party
or outside it will she will she go to
the commons today there are no plans for
that at the moment I think this
statement uh from from the treasury
which took us all by surprise at six
o'clock this morning
that will be the main event of today
that will we assume that will include
some u-turns on the mini budget measures
potentially income tax which would be
another key plank of her leadership
campaign that further undermines the
platform in which Liz trust was elected
and you've got to wonder if that goes
what does she stand for that will be the
main event of today she'll speak to her
cabinet this evening and then I think
for the trust Administration it's day by
day really
Jeremy Hunt front and center
um he's a you know a consummate
politician as you said he knows exactly
how to play this field he's had tricky
times uh he started off culture brought
the 2012 Olympics that seemed pretty
straightforward it by any measure it was
a success then he went to health the
longest serving Health secretary that
was very challenging time for him but he
he plowed on then he went to the foreign
office fancied his chances as the next
prime minister but lost heavily to Boris
Johnson in the final two yes he lost to
Boris Johnson in the final two in 2019
and ran again for the leadership this
summer and got very little support
really was was out in in some of the
very early rounds and it was quite a
disappointing performance and I think he
said at the time you probably only get
one shot at the big job and I've had it
and I didn't get the sense that over the
weekend that he was entertaining the
idea again he said look I've had my go
but he is now ask any conservative what
is the position he holds now he is the
most powerful person in this government
because he is tasked with trying to keep
them in office and mop up what even Liz
truss's closest supporters admit is a
huge mess
almost almost all of her own making and
she's fired her Chancellor with little
sense of why she feels it went wrong or
how she is going to turn things around
it is up to Jeremy Hunt to try to turn
things around starting this morning and
we'll see how many more planks of
trussinomics do go today who else who
else might be in the running to be the
next prime minister I can't believe
we're talking about another prime
minister within six weeks of this one
but there we are so I think the the
point made by Crispin blunt who's one of
the conservative MPS who's come out of
the box saying Liz trust needs to go
it's game over is that it's now the
discussion is not about whether this
trust goes it is you can read the polls
for yourself and there's another
absolutely disastrous one for the
conservatives this morning a huge poll
10 000 people
um by opinion suggesting the
conservatives would lose 200 seats and
you'd get a labor Landslide so this is
really you know 1997 levels of Labor
gains there and this is a poll
undertaken before Friday so it's now
about the mechanisms now about the
mechanism you know how do you who do you
get and how supporters of Rishi sunak
believe he can ride to the rescue he
would not be universally accepted in the
party because he's seen by many uh as
the person who began who kicked off the
downfall of Boris Johnson so how do you
get the next person in and how do you
um bluntly many conservatives don't want
the party membership involved in choose
the next leader so how do they cut them
out of it that would involve changes in
the rules and how do you get another
leader without having a general election
all of these are the questions that are
being picked over it's not as simple as
we don't like Liz trust let's have
somebody else there are lots of Hoops to
jump through the reason I was asking you
about who it might be is because we have
a list of potentially some including Ben
Wallace
Ben Wallace the defense secretary was
for many in the parties with big hope as
someone who could unite the party he
and stories over the weekend that he
might you know having not run for the
leadership this summer for personal
reasons he might consider it
um I spoke to sources close to him last
night who said that he is not putting
this about he um but he has got an
important job to do given the war in
Ukraine and that's not what he is
thinking presently although it was made
clear to me by allies of Ben Wallace
that if Liz Trust backtracked on defense
spending then that is a red line for him
and he would resign so to try and keep
all her supporters together over the
next two weeks while now you turning on
her promise not to have spending carts
and big spending cuts are expected
that's also going to be difficult you
could see things fracture very quickly
Penny Morgan did a lot of eye rolling
and nobody likes that do they in uh
during prime minister's questions last
week Penny mordant and also at the
conservative conference in Birmingham
sort of freelanced her own policies
going on on the radio saying we should
lift benefits by the level of inflation
um Penny Morden still clearly very
ambitious she's written an article in
the telegraph this morning telling her
colleagues to backlas us but also just
suggest making a few suggestions of her
own there are some in the party who hope
for what's called a joint ticket Penny
Morgan and Rishi sunak in some
combination of prime minister and Deputy
Prime Minister perhaps that would be the
sort of unity
um Unity ticket that could that could
work and could get the party behind it
but you know there there are a lot the
conservative party is deeply divided and
the idea of them uniting on anything
really is going to be very difficult we
should see like On Maneuvers at the
moment his support is certainly are they
are meeting they are dining they are
talking to journalists about how Richie
sunac predicted all of this chaos and he
could come and ride to the rescue he was
the choice of MPS not Liz Truss
could he be installed it would involve
as we were discussing changes to the
rules this is not something that
normally happens if you wanted to avoid
a proper contest lasting eight weeks
with the members having the final Choice
then that would have to involve a lot of
changes and the first step today we've
got Jeremy Hunt trying to boil his trust
some time this end you've also got a
very important amount of conservative
party gray and Brady he's the one who
keeps the letters he will be back today
so that will that that might move as
well okay we'll talk about Sir Graham
Brady in just a second just tuning our
way you're watching a special program of
the breakfast show here at on Sky News
Monday morning very rainy day is it
going to rain on Liz truss's parade
we're expecting a statement from the
chancellor mid-morning today and then
they'll be going to speak to the House
of Commons a little bit later on
basically he's more or less ripping up
what her and quasiquarting brought to us
at the end of September we've had four
chancellors in four months it is an
absolutely unprecedented amount of
turmoil for for the UK and it's been
noticed abroad I mean you know Joe Biden
the U.S president expressing his opinion
over the weekend the list of Economic
Policy wrong I mean that doesn't
normally happen this is
left MPS of all parties in despair this
state of affairs that someone has been
elected prime minister on a program
which most of her party now concede was
unrealistic and impossible to take
forward she's now having it ripped apart
by someone she's brought in as
Chancellor and is now the most important
and powerful person in the government
can this carry on for much longer is the
question they're asking themselves this
morning and how does it come to an end
looking at the four chancellors as we
chat to you four in four months as we
said yeah so before Jeremy Hunt we of
course had quasi-quarting for 38 days uh
Liz truss's key Ally but she chucked him
under the bus when the mini budget went
wrong then we briefly had Nadim zahawi
because after Rishi sunak his
predecessor resigned to try and bring
down Boris Johnson and Adam zahari was
put in that poster briefly and he's now
in a different cabinet position so four
chancellors in four months and
how many more changes may we have if Liz
trust struggles to survive because she
has a real battle on her hands remember
this is a British Parliament we're
talking about and uh and not an Italian
one under the previous labor government
I mean Gordon Bryan was a prime minister
was a Chancellor for what 10 years
yes absolutely and you you also
um you know under David Cameron you had
George Osborne for several years of
course they had ups and downs austerity
um was you know was very unpopular at
times but the the relationship between
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
was was strong they were United on on
the plan and
clearly Liz truss has taken took the
huge move of sucking quasiquating
because it was felt and this has been
confirmed to me of the weekend that he
had personally lost the Market's
confidence by enacting her plan he had
personally lost the confidence in the
market so he can't have a chance though
in that situation but she is now having
to give up everything she was elected on
and don't forget Liz truss's election
platform was all about the economy it
didn't really involve many other
subjects you know she and so you know
conservatives who were concerned that
her plan was not going to work was
unworkable and that that she was you
know by attacking all the big
institutions the office of budget
responsibility and so on she was um you
know
digging herself into a hole now feel
that this has all come home to roost and
they want to see whether there's any
chance that she can turn things around
but she was not very well known to the
public before she became prime minister
this is how she's introduced herself and
um you know I think the general feeling
is that you don't get more than one
chance to make a first impression
exactly although she's been in cabinet
more or less for the 10 years of the
Tory or coalition government so she has
been around but she says that she wants
to make a change that the previous uh
direction of travel was not the right
one and I was re-watching the interview
that we did with her
um over the um over the weekend and it's
all it was all about growth wasn't it
for Liz trust it was a huge gamble she
said that she would cut taxes in order
to secure economic growth Rishi sunak
said that's not how it works you don't
cut taxes and secure economic growth and
also a lot of the plans that she had and
was intending to bring forward this
month
shaking up planning allowing investment
zones where a lot of the current rules
don't apply a lot of that was going to
struggle to get through Parliament
anyway she has no political Capital left
now so even aside from what Jeremy Hunt
throws away today we're expecting that
her plan to cut income tax from 20p to
19p might go that's been sort of had a
cloud hangover for a couple of days now
she can't get through any of the reforms
that she wants to do in order to achieve
that growth so her agenda is gone really
and you've got to wonder therefore what
she then stands for and breaking news
just reaching us we're telling you about
that statement from the chancellor I can
tell you that it is now going to be at
11 o'clock 11 o'clock that statement
from the chancellor of course will bring
that to you live here on Sky News what
on Earth is he going to say about that
mini budget that we heard just at the
end of last month I mean he's been
ripping it to shreds already over the
weekend hasn't he how much further can
he go and in addition to that he'll be
speaking to all of the MPS in the House
of Commons at 3 30 this afternoon uh
there'll be a lot of jeers from the
labor benches I'm sure tomorrow and
we've also been hearing from the leader
of the opposition he says it's a
security issue and and Liz truss has got
to come back to speak to the House of
Commons yes Kia storm is saying that
that the prime minister is in office but
not in power the prime the public need
to know what the plan is and that she
should come to the House of Commons to
explain it she didn't really do so in
her very brief press conference on
Friday labor May secure an urgent
question for example today to on what
the government's plan is but we're
expecting Jeremy Hunt to go there at 3
30 so I think his statement to the
commons will be the main event today
you'd expect Liz trust to be sitting
beside him or the sort of criminologists
will be watching who's sitting next to
who and how many glum faces you can see
behind them but the conservative party
is not a happy ship there are people
actively plotting to replace the prime
minister with someone else and thinking
in quite specific terms about how they
might achieve that and she she said to
allies before second quasi-quarting it
was reported they're coming for me she
knows that the party now many serious
people in the party want rid of her
she's got rid of her Chancellor she's
got rid of her economic plan really with
it with just a couple of exceptions and
so it's going to be very very Touch and
Go so over the next couple of weeks to
see whether things can study but the
first step is brought forward today some
of the measures from the mini budget we
expect more u-turns and can it steady
the markets to buy her a bit of time to
turn things around anyone seen Boris
Johnson
no he was reported to have been in the
U.S on the current polling not just what
we've seen today but in general he would
really struggle to hold on to his
parliamentary seat in Oxbridge so if he
was thinking of staying in politics he'd
want to avoid a general election
um there are some in the conservative
party who believe that maybe he can ride
to their rescue bring him back I'm not
sure those around him say that's not
what he's thinking about yeah you know
I'm just going to put my neck out there
and said that's just not going to happen
isn't it but I mean
in all seriousness how much longer can
this prime minister hold on or can she
you know ride this storm and then it is
raining this morning and get through the
next two years before the general
election because if there's a general
election before then as we've seen from
that latest poll the tour is the toast I
think to be honest most conservatives
are now thinking about what happens in
the next two weeks the the full fiscal
plan is coming at the end of October
that's still happening so the chancellor
will be making some announcements today
we expect he'll row back on some more
budget measures
um but the full plan including the
painful spending cuts we now expect and
he has outlined will come at the end of
October so the first challenge really is
to get to that point to get to the end
of October the when the plan is
announced it is not going to
you know announcing big painful spending
cuts including to the NHS at a time of
cost of living squeeze he didn't rule
out cuts to education defense all
government departments might be in the
firing line all that's going to be very
difficult so that's going to be the
first big hurdle and then after that
where where does the Prime Minister Go I
mean it's it's hard to say anything
other than that she has lost power and
that Jeremy Hunt is now really in charge
of the government's economic Direction
he needs to just buy her a bit of time
okay um sir Roger Gale is with us now
hello to you sir Roger thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
could you have predicted any of this
no
quite simply
um because I I didn't see it coming in
this way
um I I said after the mini budget The
Fortunes favored the brave but not the
foolhardy and I felt at the time that
that was full Hardy but that at least I
suppose has been proved right but the
rest of it no I don't think many people
predicted how this was going to play out
or is playing out
uh what do you think uh Jeremy Hunt's up
to
I think Jeremy Hunt has taken on the job
it's quite clear that he's taken on the
job on his terms
that he said he will do it but he'll
only do it if he can do what he believes
to be necessary to stabilize markets to
stabilize the economy
and to get the show back on track and
that's what he's doing and there is real
power in Downing Street but it's not in
number 10 it's in number 11.
why is he having why is he announcing
another statement today why is he not
waiting going through the books working
with the Prime Minister and waiting
until the 31st of October which is a
date which has already been brought
forward for another look at this prime
minister's fiscal plans
what I think the chancellor is seeking
to do is to stabilize the markets pure
and simple at this stage that um longer
term plan will be announced on the 31st
of October as I understand it and that
will be make or break both for the new
Chancellor and also for the Prime
Minister if if she's still in post at
that time and I have to say that
because it may be that she will review
her own position
but look okay what I'm concerned about
and what I think we all be concerned
about is the fact that this is real
people's real lives real Homes real
small businesses that are at stake this
is not or shouldn't be about the
conservative party but about the future
of the country and the economy and I
genuinely think that that is what Jeremy
Hunt is seeking to address we've got to
keep the market stable to allow
ourselves time to get through this and
to come out hopefully On the Sunny Side
so Roger how has your party got itself
in this mess
apparently with considerable ease
um
I I
um it's no secret I I did not vote for
Mrs trust and just for the record I
didn't vote for issues sunac either uh
in the final ballot I felt that I'd had
my say and others had to have their set
in the party
chose Mrs trust she came forward with a
plan which was bold and brave
but as I've said I think foolhardy she
didn't she's acknowledged it she didn't
roll the pitch she didn't prepare the
ground
and her Chancellor didn't prepare the
ground so
everybody was caught I think to a large
extent on the Hop and the markets don't
like that that's led to a situation that
is I'm afraid of a financial situation
that yes is heavily influenced by global
Affairs but also
is very much of our own making
do you agree with what she was trying to
achieve
I think we could probably certainly on
our side of the house all agree with
what she was trying to achieve in the
sense that we are and want to be a low
tax party and we are and historically
have been and want to be
in support of growth the economy has
been flatlining for far too long
what she's sought to do
was to stimulate growth in a very big
way indeed
but in order to do that she took some
measures that quite clearly were not
palatable not acceptable either to the
public or to the markets and that has
been what may well prove to be her done
for
but what she said she was trying to do
along with her previous chancellor who
can say that after 38 days was to
stimulate the economy in order to try
and get growth of two and a half percent
that's not going to happen is it now
well whether that happens or not will
depend upon what this Chancellor does
and how he does it I obviously hope that
he'll succeed in stimulating that growth
but what she did and what her Chancellor
at the time did what cause he quoting
did
was to make significant Cuts in tax
unfunded and that's what spooked
everybody where is the money coming from
she had already quite rightly
and correctly sought to bail out
People's Energy bills for not only for
this winter we have to remember which is
what the labor party were talking about
doing but for two years at very
considerable cost that was the right
thing to do what she should have done in
my view is to have stopped there
quarter breath looked at the whole scene
and then come forward with a properly
prepared proposal
what actually happened was that the mini
budget was rushed out
without sufficient preparation without
sufficient thought and without
sufficient explanation That's What's led
to the downfall of her first Chancellor
and may well lead I feared to her
downfall
as we know Mr Roger MPS did not want her
to be the next prime minister as you
said quite rightly they wanted it to be
Richie sooner but the members did
were the members wrong
I think
members of parliament probably have a
better perspective of both the economic
situation and the personalities
than the general membership for very
good reason we know them we work with
them day by day
the general membership doesn't and and
that's understandable and I don't think
we should expect I'm not seeking to
blame the membership for getting it
wrong
it was not my choice but I we have to
accept we live in a democracy we accept
the system as it is but look again the
situation we face now unfortunately is a
lot of people apparently although I
don't rely on newspapers for saying how
many letters have gone into Graham Brady
and those letters at the moment aren't
worth the paper they're written on
because the rules would have to be
changed in order to have a leadership
election and God knows the last thing we
want is another leadership election
you've then got a situation where if the
Prime Minister were to decide that her
position was untenable
and she went
then there will have to be I think a
coronation now in order for that to
happen
you've got to have an agreed candidate
and at the moment I see no single agreed
candidate within the party
could there not be a coalition of the
sides
um we know that Rishi sunak and Penny
mordant despite them saying they're not
they are both clearly on maneuvers
well um Penny Morton has been saying and
she's absolutely right to say that what
we need at the moment is stability and
that is what Jeremy Hunt is trying to
inject I think into the situation I said
earlier and I will say again that
the power in Downing Street is in number
11 not number 10. I think Jeremy Hunt is
de facto prime minister at the moment
and I hope that he will be able that
he's a very experienced man he's had
long experience in cabinets he's been
foreign secretary as well as the health
secretary
he's a businessman a self-made
businessman he understands economics and
I think he can get this right but it's
quite clear
that all the shots are now being called
from number 11 and in a way I have to
say I'm very pleased that they are
because I think that will stabilize the
markets and I hope that we can find a
way forward for the United Kingdom for
our country not for the conservative
party
is that because uh Jeremy Hunt is prime
ministerial and the Prime Minister
doesn't know what she's doing
I think Jeremy Hunt does know what he's
doing and I'm not going to seek to take
side swipes that anybody else at all I
just think that we've got now
the right man in the job at the time
people rise to occasions and I think
that I hope that Jeremy will I wish him
well in his Endeavors for the sake of
the country because if he gets this
wrong then we're going to go to hell in
a Hancock but if we get it right then we
can emerge from this I think better and
stronger and we can start to move
forward in the direction that we all
really want to go
would he be a good prime minister
well
I supported him
for the Premiership when he stood
against Boris Johnson so not
surprisingly I would have to say
absolutely yes to that but that's not
the game that he appears to be in he's
doing a job he's getting on with the job
I hope and I I think and everything
that's coming out of number 11 suggests
that he's working very hard and very
fast
through men's and fences so let's let
him get on and do the job
and take each step I think as it comes
I'll be very interested to see what he
says from the treasury later this
morning
uh just a reflection Before I Let You Go
um the prime minister's news conference
on Friday how did you react to that I'm
sure you were watching it either live or
caught it soon after
it was commendably brief
I think I was interested to note that
the four journalists who were allowed to
ask questions didn't ask the one
question but I and I suspect by a lot of
other people one did asked which was
given that you are joined at the hip
with your Chancellor given that you all
believe you both believe in the same
policies given that you prepared the
mini budget together why have you sacked
him
nobody answered that question
but nobody else
yeah to be fair she didn't take many
questions though did she
no but I would for me if I if I've been
one of those journalists present if I'd
been Harry Cole for example and given
the opportunity to ask the question
that's the question that I'd have asked
first
how do you expect Before I Let You Go
final question how do you expect today
to pan out
this is the final final question is that
I didn't mind in the slices I'm very
happy to talk yeah yeah well unless I
think of another one
I think what will happen I hope what
will happen is that Jeremy Hunt will
come forward
with some quick measures to stabilize
the markets to give the markets the
confidence that we need before the
Market's open today which
um as uh as your political correspondent
said quite correctly why the statement
is being made from the treasury and not
in the House of Commons as normally and
courteously it would be and as the
speaker no doubt would like it but
because it's Monday because the house is
sitting at 2 30 not at 11 30 and the
markets will be open but your chance of
executive clearly wants to make his
pitch now in order to tell the markets
that the country's in safe hands and I
hope that they will accept that
it's always great to talk to you and get
your perspective so Roger thank you very
much indeed if you're just tuning our
way let me tell you we are we've got a
special program for you live from
Downing Street on the Morning Show on
Sky news this morning and that is
because the prime minister is back at
her desk at Downey Street this morning
but we have already heard from the
chancellor and the chancellor of either
treasury has told us that there will be
another briefing at 11 o'clock this
morning about the mini budget that we
heard at the end of September he will
then speak to the House of Commons and
the Chamber at proper that's at 3 30
this afternoon what on Earth might you
say here's tomorrow good morning
good morning Kay well Jeremy Hunt took
Everyone by surprise just after six
o'clock this morning we put out a a
statement by the treasury that he would
be announcing some of the mini budget
u-turns early this morning he will be
bringing forward some of what we
expected the balancing the books plan
from the end of this month to today why
because he wants to send an urgent
signal to the market that the country is
now going down a different path than it
was under Liz truss's plan we expect
that some more of her measures
potentially the plan cut to income tax
or some of the other tax cuts she had
planned might now Fall by the wayside we
will hear from the chancellor later this
morning on that he says it's to ensure
fiscal sustainability to show that the
country can pay its bills and balance
the books and this comes after a weekend
in which he held talks with Liz truss at
Checkers and he made very clear Jeremy
Hunt in a series of interviews that she
had made big mistakes that the country
had been Flying Blind without proper
forecasts and that you couldn't have tax
cuts without paying for them so sounds
like Jeremy Hunt is now in charge of the
government's economic policy and the
changes begin today we'll get the full
plan including the details of what could
be quite painful spending cuts at the
end of this month but certainly it's
assigned to the market
from the off today and it will perhaps
buy Liz trust a bit of time because the
plotting is underway in earnest Ian's
with us Ian what do you think
well okay well I mean it's uh Jeremy
Hunt in his interviews over the weekend
said that uh everything was on the table
other than of course uh that reversal in
the National Insurance increases which
obviously has largely been legislated
for but that was a big ticket spending
item that was some 12 billion pounds or
so on its own and with the Institute of
fiscal studies saying that he's got a 60
billion pound black hole to fill well
one wonders what other measures are
going to be uh announced today I mean
obviously they've already reversed the
45p measure that saved two billion
pounds uh they've delayed the 1p off the
basic rate of income tax that saved
another five and a quarter billion
pounds but that's obviously uh gone and
of course corporation tax the reversal
there not going ahead now that's uh a
big ticket item that's another 12
billion pounds or so but that still
leaves quite a lot of money to be saved
I suspect that public spending will not
be rising in line with inflation other
measures I wonder whether they might
actually be tempted to tamper with some
of the support for energy bills for how
households and businesses now of course
at the moment this is an across the
board support that's being offered and a
lot of people including the IMF last
week said well do you really need to uh
support well-off households with their
energy bills uh it's something that uh
other countries have been looking at as
well um the IMF was very critical last
week of countries that have been
offering across the board support both
France and Germany have adopted a
similar line to that of the UK but if
you were to only limit support on energy
bills to the very lowest income
households well that would be a
substantial saving and that might be I
wonder One measure that Jeremy Hunt
might deploy to make his numbers stack
up I can tell you in the meantime the
markets well obviously the guilt Market
isn't open yet all eyes on guilt yields
we had a big spike in those on Friday
afternoon after uh the initial recovery
post the dismissal of quasi-cartes and
currently uh 10-year Guild deals on
Friday night uh were at 4.37 the 20 year
was at four point eight nine two percent
and the Thirty Year at four point eight
oh eight percent so all eyes on those in
the meantime Sterling has uh rallied uh
overnight on the Asia Pacific markets
now bear in mind that uh Sterling isn't
a heavily traded currency in that part
of the world so there's not a lot of
liquidity uh but even so Sterling which
was uh trading at one dollar eleven
seven uh at the end of last week is
currently uh changing hands at around 1.
1305 so that's a gain of around nine
tenths of one percent against the US
dollar from where it was on Friday
evening it's up by around three quarters
of one percent right now against the
Euro so if you if you want to uh look
for indications of how the market might
react to uh this uh this bringing
forward of these announcements and you
would say that that was relatively
positive obviously Sterling came off
quite sharply on Friday night as well I
think it's also really really
interesting uh that's a brief statement
that we had from the treasury this
morning that they made clear that Jeremy
Hunt had briefed not only Andrew Bailey
the governor of the bank of England
someone one that viewers may not have
heard of as well was also brief the head
of the debt management office a
gentleman uh his sir Bob stamens Sir
Robert stamen now uh the interesting
thing about the debt management office
is these are the people that have to uh
run the government's borrowing uh the
clues in the name debt management office
these are the people that issue guilt to
the market uh make an assessment of what
the market will and won't go for in
terms of when they're selling guilts to
raise money uh in government uh boring
so very interesting I thought that both
he was briefed as well as Andrew Bailey
okay
um Ian I know that we've got Ian King
live from you at 10 but I'm sure we'll
hear from you again before then thanks
very much indeed just tuning our way let
me tell you uh that we're bringing our
program from Downing Street for you this
morning after an announcement just after
six o'clock this morning that there will
be another statement from the new
Chancellor the fourth in four months
you'll be talking about that mini budget
at about 11 o'clock this morning we'll
bring that to you live here on Sky News
then at 3 30 he will be speaking to the
Chamber of the House of Commons in other
words speaking to MPS it should be the
other way around but they come back late
on a Monday from their constituency
business so as a result he's going to be
speaking to the nation first at 11
o'clock and we'll bring that to you live
on Sky how is he going to balance the
books from the figures we've seen over
the weekend he's going to have to have
swathing cuts across most of government
is what some people are saying up to 15
in some departments could that mean
defense we've heard from Ben Wallace who
is the defense secretary up until now he
has been fiercely loyal to the Prime
Minister but has said do not touch my
budget if she does what happens next
Deborah Haynes is with us Deborah it's
crucially important for him not least
because of the situation in Ukraine
it is and today you've got news of more
explosions in Kiev the mayor of Kiev
saying that several residential
buildings have been hit you've also got
an advisor to the president saying that
these are Iranian Kamikaze drones that
have been causing the destruction this
morning in the capital a Guardian
newspaper journalist Dan saber has
tweeted that he has literally just
arrived overnight to Kiev station this
morning and is waiting in an underpass
after what he described as multiple
drone strikes nearby a really terrifying
reminder of this devastating War that's
taking place in Ukraine Russia's
invasion of Ukraine a reminder of the
vital importance of security and how
threatened security across Europe is and
that is exactly why things like the
defense budget and what happens to
defense spending and how the UK is able
to rebuild its hollowed out Armed Forces
is so vitally important as you say and
that's why all eyes will be on what
Jeremy Hunt says later this morning in
terms of the defense budget the Prime
Minister made very clear in her bid for
the Tory leadership for the job that
she's in now that she planned to lift
the defense budget
um to 2.5 percent of national income by
2026 and then to three percent of
national income by 2030 that's going to
be an extra
157 billion pounds which is an
extraordinary large amount of money but
at a time when there is a war in Europe
you cannot squimp with your budget and
every time you hear from this Chancellor
and also his very recent predecessor
talking about the economic choices they
need to make they they say that there
cannot be long-term defense spending
without Economic Security without
economic stability but in reality you
cannot have economic stability without
security and that requires defense
spending
okay Deborah from now thanks for
explaining that to us of course we'll
bring you more on that statement that
we're expecting from the chancellor 11
o'clock this morning you can see it live
on the Sky News in just a few moments
time but before that I want to tell you
about a report from the Metropolitan
Police it's found that hundreds of
police officers may have been getting
away with committing misconduct so Mark
Rowley who as you know is the new met
police chief said that he will urgently
confront the culture this is what he had
to say
the report Brands the Metropolitan
Police internal discipline system has
systematically flawed racist misogynist
too slow and ineffective the evidence
around racial disparity in the
metropolitan policies misconduct system
is so grave and so shocking that even in
2021 81 of black staff and officers are
more likely to be in the misconduct
system than their white counterparts is
truly awful what I'm saying is the
internal misconduct system is an example
of what I would call institutional
racism the report found that black staff
were 81 percent more likely than white
to face a misconduct allegation sexual
and other discrimination complaints were
less likely than others to be
investigated misconduct cases took an
average 400 Days to be resolved and 20
percent of accused staff were involved
in two or more cases
the report highlights the case of one
officer who faced 11 misconduct hearings
over sexual harassment assault fraud and
other allegations some were proved some
were dismissed he kept his job and is
still a serving officer the report said
up to 60 percent of misconduct
allegations were dismissed leaving staff
who complained feeling that nothing
happens we've been sacking a bit less
than one a week so maybe 40 or 50 a year
um
based on this report which clearly says
that we have been far too soft there
must be hundreds in the organization
that I need to get rid of some of them
are unethical and don't deserve to be a
cop and
don't deserve to be wearing uniform and
some of what they're doing in many cases
is Criminal a former met officer said
accused police should not get special
treatment I think it's absolutely
appalling that the police are not held
to the same standards as members of the
community are and the fact that they can
get away with one offense two offenses
or three offenses without going to court
and without losing their jobs is
appalling and that will affect trust and
confidence with the many communities of
London the home office said it would
review the whole police disciplinary
process the full Casey review of the
Mets culture and standards of behavior
is expected to be published in the New
Year Martin brunt Sky News Scotland Yard
okay we'll obviously bring you more on
that from Martin let's bring in John
rental now so should we um hello to Mr
rental very keen to get your first
thoughts on the situation as it's
developing this morning a decisive day
for our prime minister
good morning Kate uh yes the chancellor
will be telling us his first thoughts
about how he's going to make the sums
add up as he said uh at the weekend uh
we've got to remember that he's had the
office for Budget responsibility
forecast of of the economy for or at
least the treasury has had it for for a
week I mean he hasn't been there for a
week
um and so he's going to I think tell us
this morning his initial conclusions
because we know that the corporation tax
uh Rises back we know that's going to
happen we know there's a huge additional
Gap in the public finances it still has
to be bridged and I think he's going to
set out his uh his broad uh thoughts on
that before the office for Budget
responsibility goes goes away reworks it
sums uh and then decides whether or not
he gets a tick in the margin of his
medium-term fiscal plan uh on Halloween
yeah but we knew those things already
didn't we so what else might he be able
to say to steady the markets or is it
just that we have got a prime minister
a protein slip we have got a Chancellor
that the markets has faith in finally
we've got an acting prime minister in
the shape of uh Jeremy Hunt who is
making all the decisions and he's going
to tell us what some of those decisions
are because we know that there's this
there's this huge gap still I mean
raising corporation tax is a is a what
Ian King there just described as a big
ticket measure I mean that is a that's
18 billion pounds a year that's a
significant sum of money uh but it's
still an awful long way short of of the
uh of the amount of money that's
actually needed uh to make the sums add
up so Jeremy Hunt I think is going to
tell us uh this morning uh what the rest
of the big ticket items are one of them
is obviously going to be spending cuts
he might put a figure on that but he's
got to tell us whether that income tax
uh basic rate income tax cut is going to
stay
I'm sure it's not I'm sure that's gonna
I'm sure that's going to go but where
else is he going to get the money from
uh all eyes are going to be on him
yeah he may well say as has been
predicted that he's going to push that
back that Penny cut until the year after
which of course is what Rishi sunak has
suggested that he would scrap it all
together okay I mean there's no age
until the year after it's it's gone
okay
um
who do you think his audience is
well it is primarily uh the the market
uh we'll see what uh what they do uh
this morning it's so I mean it looks as
if from the from the behavior of the
pound as if the markets are reassured to
an extent uh but it'll be fascinating to
Watch What Happens uh to the guilt
Market in particular that's the market
for government debt uh when he makes his
his statement this morning and and I
don't I don't know whether he's going to
say more in the in the House of Commons
uh this afternoon but uh it'll be worth
watching watching all of that and then
beyond that of course his Market is is
conservative MPS in the General Public
because he has to reassure them that the
government is back on track
is he completely undermining this prime
minister is she is she a lame duck prime
minister now I think she undermined
herself gay uh she I mean she has blown
up her Premiership uh after after 38
days uh it does seem to be all over uh
but I mean she will presumably survive
for the time being now that uh now that
you know there is an acting prime
minister in charge who is making the
decisions uh but conservative MPS have
got to decide what to do with her I mean
there's no point having a a uh a sort of
proxy prime minister who's just just
there to fill the space uh they they
need to
um sort out the government they need to
decide who they want as prime minister
they need to let the conservative party
members nowhere near that decision uh
that's going to cause absolute ruptions
in the conservative party uh but they've
got to sort it out and they've got to
sort it out quickly
again I I asked whether she is a lamed
up prime minister
yeah no she I mean the only question is
when is she going to stop being prime
minister uh and that depends on
conservative MPS getting their act
together whether they've got the unity
and the discipline uh to decide uh who's
going to replace that because uh uh they
can't afford another another leadership
election where the where the party
members decide they've got to decide and
you know the obvious choices are uh
Rishi Rishi sunak uh possibly Jeremy
Hunt or Penny Morton's now I would have
thought of those uh Rishi sunak is the
one most likely to uh command the
confidence of the mark not just the
markets but the uh but the wider
population
what about Ben Wallace
well yes he's a he's a compromised
candidate but he didn't run last time
for his own personal reasons I don't
know if those are still uh those are
still current he's very much untested
though I mean the thing about Rishi
sunak is he's been a chancellor of the
exchequer he knows uh how to run the
economy uh and he's an extremely good
communicator uh and so he I think is the
person you could slot in without any
without any worries uh except of course
for the conservative party members who
don't like him because they regard him
as the Assassin of of their their hero
Boris Johnson but I mean I'm afraid
they'll just have to lump it
I want to watch Boris Johnson's thinking
this morning as he's brushing his teeth
I mean he must be one of several people
who are quite uh quite pleased that his
successor has been such a failure but I
mean he can't can't seriously want the
country to be in such a terrible State
um so yes I think he he probably still
Harbors uh thoughts of making a comeback
I mean that is a very sort of johnsonian
uh thing to imagine that he'll be called
back like uh Charles de Gaulle uh from
his uh from his retirement home to save
the nation but I don't think that's
going to happen because his MPS don't
trust him and the and the wider public
don't trust him either
The Wider public you know they've not
had a say in uh this prime minister
um have they um look what look what's
happened she's still in power for now
she may be in two years time we don't
know it's just a very very difficult day
for her and for the government but I
wonder how much more the public will
take without not having another general
election we've seen the latest opinion
polls suggesting that if there was an
election tomorrow the Tories would lose
200 seats
yes with that but that is why while uh
Liz truss is still prime minister I
think that would change if uh if the
conservatives had a different leader I
don't think I don't think it would
change to a to to a much better position
but I mean it is certainly worth it from
conservative MP's point of view it's
worth saving it saving some of their
seats I mean it could be it could be 50
to 100 seats uh if if they get to if
they get a better leader uh but you know
you're right the the pub the general
public uh think that there should be a
general election because I mean if the
conservatives get another prime minister
uh without a mandate from the general
public and so much has changed since the
last general election 2019. uh we've had
coronavirus and now the energy crisis uh
and all those Manifesto promises in in
2019 I mean they've all they've all gone
up and spoke the promise not to raise
taxes uh which is what uh Liz truss uh
majored on when she ran for the
leadership uh those are all gone so it
there's a very very strong case for
going back to the people and asking them
uh to choose
I was speaking to friends over the
weekend and they said we can't have two
unelected prime ministers it's starting
to look like North Korea well it started
yet it's starting to look like past the
parcel who ends up with the uh with the
with the rather Tatty parcel uh and I
think that that does look bad from the
from the point of view of the general
public but I'm afraid I don't think a
general election is very likely because
as you say the opinion polls are in such
a state even if a new leader could pull
it back a bit uh I think that would be
uh that that would be very difficult for
the conservatives
um you've got to remember that the the
choice of an election uh since the
repeal of the fixture and Parliament Act
is in the hands of the Prime Minister
alone uh Liz truss is not going to go to
the country uh but uh and her successor
is very unlikely to either so I think we
will have to wait uh unfortunately for a
general election but it is something
that people do feel very strongly about
wait until wait until when do you think
can she can she survive another
two years
oh no she's she's not going to survive
um uh very long uh I mean I wouldn't I
wouldn't necessarily believe uh
conservative MP to confidently talk
about getting rid of her by Christmas uh
I mean we were in this situation before
with at the beginning of this year with
Boris Johnson I mean conservative MPS
had had enough of him they wanted him
out but they they couldn't agree on who
to replace him with and that meant that
he he stayed for for longer than he
possibly should have done and the same
applies to to Liz trust now but I mean I
think she is so damaged
um that they do have to get rid of her
and if they don't get rid of her before
Christmas it'll be it'll be fairly soon
after I would have I would have thought
uh so the but but then the next the next
prime minister does have some time until
January 2025 uh to try and put the uh
put the pieces of the uh the broken bars
back together again
okay so you think that we will still
have a conservative government in 2025
. well well that's the latest uh legal
dates that you can have a general
election is in January 2025 and if if
the conservative party is heading for a
defeat I think they will uh they will go
as go stay in office for as long as they
can
I understand that data I just wondered
whether you you think that they will be
able to limp along until then yes
because in the end as I say the decision
is going to be made by the Prime
Minister and if there is a conservative
prime minister they're not going to want
to go to the country it's fairly odd
it's fairly simple uh unless there's a
complete breakdown in in discipline okay
and morale
sadly we're out of time job it's always
great to talk to you thanks so much
India for your expertise much
appreciated thank you we are live
outside number 11 Downing Street this
morning on the breakfast show here on
Sky News it stopped raining does that
mean it stopped raining on the prime
minister's parade don't know we're
expecting a news conference or certainly
a statement from the new Chancellor at
11 o'clock this morning we'll carry it
for you live here on Sky News stay tuned